that includes the synthesis report
technical support unit and working group
tsus
lastly on behalf of the ipcc I offer my
deepest thanks to the Swiss government
for hosting this meeting in Interlaken
the synthesis report marks the end of an
extraordinary process
it has produced the world's most
comprehensive assessment of the climate
change science the risks of climate
change and response options
the report will serve as the the
resource for policy makers at a critical
moment in history
a time when it is imperative that
climate action become a much higher
priority
the synthesis report brings together the
key findings from three previous special
reports and three working group reports
it stands on the shoulders of giants
that brings forth
its own insights and perspectives
the report offers hope
and it provides a warning it warns that
the pace and scale of what has been done
so far and current plans are
insufficient to tackle climate change
the rapid and sustained emissions
reductions and accelerated adaptation
action is required in this decade to
address climate change
we are working when we should be
sprinting
in 2018 the ipcc highlighted the
challenge of keeping warming to 1.5
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
levels
five years later the challenge is even
greater
the impacts of human cause climate
change are unfolding with bracing
Clarity more frequent and more intense
droughts are
more intense droughts and flooding
threats to our food and water security
illness and death
the report shows that climate impacts
are undermining our
the global economy and the impacts
threaten our life support system the
nature itself
every increment of warming will lead to
rapidly escalating hazards and widening
Regional differences when the risks
combined with other diverse events such
as pandemics or conflicts they become
increasingly difficult to manage
sadly as the report makes clear losses
and damages are part of our future but
the report also emphasizes that
effective and Equitable climate Action
Now can lead to a more sustainable
resilient and just world and more
ambitious action will provide wider
benefits for nature and people
the report points to multiple feasible
and effective options to reduce
Greenhouse greenhouse gas emissions and
adapt to climate change and those
options for change are already available
the question is can we deploy those
options quickly and effectively
enough to cut emissions to create a
safer sustainable future for everyone
can we protect ourselves with more
resilient practices and infrastructure
that's the challenge limiting warming to
1.5 degrees Celsius requires deep rapid
and sustained reductions in greenhouse
gas emissions in all sectors
emissions will need to be cut by almost
half by 2030 if we want a chance to stay
at or below 1.5 degrees Celsius more
reductions will need to follow but
Action Now along many dimensions could
result in the transformational changes
session to the future we all wish for a
future not just for ourselves but for
generations to come we already know how
to proceed on many fronts the report
identifies tried and tested policies and
practices that can work in diverse in
diverse contexts to reduce emissions and
Advance climate resilience
but they need to be scaled up and
applied more widely lowering demand for
carbon intensive goods and service
carbon intensive equipment Services is a
particularly promising way to reduce
emissions
when it comes to buildings for example
lowering demand could reduce emissions
by 66 percent by 2050 even higher
potential demand side reductions
available in land transportation and
electricity one of the reports essential
findings is the value of fairness those
who contributed the least to climate
change are often the most vulnerable to
its impacts in the previous decade
people who lived in areas highly
vulnerable to climate impacts were up to
15 times I repeat up to 15 times more
likely to die in floods droughts and
storms money cannot solve everything but
it is critical to narrowing the gap
between those who are most vulnerable
and those who enjoy greater security
the report finds the path to a safer
more Equitable and sustainable future
for all requires three to six times the
current amount of financing but there's
enough financial resources to rapidly
reduce greenhouse gas emissions it's not
just about the quantity of money
it's also about how and where it is
allocated vulnerable areas just don't
have enough money to fund the urgent
need to adapt to climate change but
there are ways to reduce the barriers
that hold back investment
governments through Public Funding and
clear signals to investors have a key
role to play in reducing these barriers
it's critical that climate action makes
everyone healthier and safer
climate Solutions extend well beyond
financial and Technical responses
support for healthier Lifestyles for
example can can be good for us and good
for the climate yes it is good news that
the cost of solar and wind power Has
Fallen
the report underscores that clean
renewable energy is absolutely among the
most promising and effective options for
climate action but there is more
holistic approach
it's what we call climate resilient
development it involves integrating
measures to adapt to climate change with
actions to reduce or avoid emissions in
ways that provide wider benefits to all
benefits like improving People's Health
and livelihoods reducing poverty and
hunger providing Clean Energy Water and
Air
the economic benefits for People's
Health from air quality improvement
alone would be enough
roughly the same and possibly even
larger than the cost of reducing or
avoiding emissions
we also know that the path to a more
secure future requires political
commitment and inclusive governance it
relies on International cooperation
ecosystem stewardship and the sharing of
diverse knowledge values and World Views
lastly climate action requires the best
of humanity the report underscores the
value of trust collaboration and sharing
of the benefits and burdens it calls on
all of us collectively individually to
do what is in our capacity to make a
difference we need to recognize that we
live in a diverse world in in which
everyone has different responsibilities
and different opportunities to enact
change
some can do a lot While others will need
help managing the change and that change
will be shaped by the choice we choices
we make
starting right now so let's hope we make
the right choices because the ones we
make now and in the next few years will
reverberate around the world for
hundreds even thousands of years thank
you very much we will now take your
questions
before we take questions just to say
that we've managed to reconnect with Dr
talas the Secretary General wmo
if you can hear us could you please
um
could you please come in
Dr talas is is in Helsinki so I
understand you only have a few minutes
Dr tell us we can see you and hear you
Dr Thomas we can see you and hear you
please go ahead
help
uh biosphere food security deputies and
global economy many of those risks could
be avoided if he would reach instead 1.5
degrees warm
W mobile published its state of climate
report in a few weeks where we will show
that all of the climate parameters are
moving into totally wrong direction
temperatures ocean warming ocean
acidification melting of glaciers sea
level rise flooding and Route events and
concentrations of main greenhouse gases
carbon dioxide methane
oxide good news is that we have both
economically technically attractive
means to limit the warming even to the
1.5 degrees that the transition is also
a great opportunity for new businesses
and the financial savings
at wmov at the moment promoting early
warning services for all initiative to
improve early warning services in other
countries which do not have a proper
multi-hazard early warning services in
place and have major gaps also in their
basic weather and climate observing
systems it is it is one of the most
effective ways to mitigate the climate
risk to invest in early warning services
we have also a new initiative to monitor
sources of and sinks of carbon dioxide
the methane and nitrous oxide by using
ground-based satellite measurements and
the models to assess what's happening in
the real atmosphere and this is supposed
to be endorsed by the forthcoming cop
28.
our scientific advisory panel and the
world climate research program have
recommended establishment of a kilometer
scale a climate modeling system
to improve the cloud species
parametrization and future estimates of
weather extremes like flooding drought
and and also to assess the risks of of
Antarctic
melting and and dramatic sea level rise
up to 10 meters in the future
finally I would like to express my great
thanks for the authors and hosts of of
the technical support units for your
hard work during the past six years and
and to accomplish these sixth assessment
report fully and also to accomplish the
three special reports thank you
thank you very much Secretary General
tell us we will now try to bring in the
unip executive director
Inger Anderson
anger the floor is yours
um yes good morning good afternoon
finger Anderson here from New York as we
start out the Water conference let me
start out by first thanking the ipcc
chair of course XCOM the bureau the
authors and the Secretariat for their
work done during the sixth assessment
cycle which has culminated in this the
summary for policy makers of the census
report of the six assessment cycle to
all congratulations
so what does the synthesis report tell
us well it tells us and we know that the
climate change is here now it tells us
that climate change is a real threat to
human and planetary well-being it tells
us of course that these human and
planetary well-being are one and the
same it tells us that we are very very
close to 1.5 degrees limit and that
there is even and that even this limit
is not safe for people and for planet
and it tells us that climate change is
throwing its hardest punches at the most
vulnerable communities who bear the
least responsibility as we just saw with
Cyclone Freddie in Malawi Mozambique and
Madagascar and as we saw with flash
floods in Turkey just recently and which
killed together hundreds of people this
report
tells us that our Collective failure to
cut greenhouse gas emissions leaves us
on track to exceed 1.5 five degrees
Celsius of global warming and that
continuing to March down this track will
bring further intensification of extreme
weather of ecosystem degradation and of
damage to lives and livelihoods
so we must turn down the heat we must
help vulnerable communities to adapt to
those impacts of climate change that are
already here the synthesis report which
chimes with unep's own research tells us
that we already have the technology and
the know-how to get the job done
renewable energy instead of fossil fuels
Energy Efficiency green transport green
Urban infrastructure halting
deforestation ecosystem restoration
sustainable Food Systems including
reduced food loss and waste investing in
these areas and more besides will help
to stabilize our climate reduce nature
and biodiversity loss and pollution and
waste the other two prongs of the triple
planetary crisis
deliver many other benefits from cleaner
air and healthier nature to decent jobs
and more Equity it is frankly the
ultimate no-brainer ahead of us this
year lie the U.N climate action Summit
in September in New York and the first
Global stop take under the pairs
agreement at cop 28 in the UAE these
will undoubtedly be important moments to
set the tone for action in the second
half of this critical decade
but if there's one clear takeaway from
the synthesis report for Nations for
businesses for investors and for every
individual who contributes to climate
change it is this we must move from
climate procrastination to climate
activation and we must begin this today
thank you
thank you very much for these thoughtful
words we will now move to questions and
I'll first turn to the room
Christian the floor is yours could one
of the microphones be brought to
Christian
hello my name is Christiana with the
German press agency and my question is
is this is a report that has been
approved by governments so basically
governments are talking to themselves
here with their dire warnings which is a
bit bizarre but I guess the question the
problem is that a warning and action are
two different things so I wonder whether
you could give us in a nutshell what is
your message to those people who are in
power today
and what is your message to the people
out there who um who are wondering what
they can do now as concretely as
possible thank you
thank you very much for that question
and this our report the census report
can be summarized as a message of Hope
and we know that the the world has
suffered greatly from ongoing climate
change
problems and if the demand of energy
demand and Supply patterns will continue
as we have seen so far and then we will
suffer more in the future and this
report clearly emphasized that we do
have technology and know-how and tools
to solve for the climate problems and
for instance we have analyzed greatly
about the consumption patterns and
production patterns and
specifically we have found that great
there's great deal of room for
improvement in the energy efficiencies
to such to the tune of can be the demand
energy consumption can be reduced by 40
to 70 percent in some sectors using the
next two decades that will contribute
greatly in reducing the greenhouse gas
emissions
another instance is the we found that a
great deal of the the potential for
reduction in future greenhouse gas
emissions in the urban centers by
pursuing a very comprehensive a
climate-friendly climate friendly
development patterns those are just few
examples of the the
programs and investment patterns that
countries globally countries can take to
reduce the threats of climate change now
and for the future now with regard to
the some detailed technical aspects of
the message I invite section
facilitators to jump in
so one of the critical enablers of
action that we talked about is the role
of finance and financing for investment
uh and the message is not really
governments addressing it at the core at
the core is the financial system needs
to be able to respond to the challenges
ahead and there's plenty of financing
that's available for multiple reasons
and multiple activities but our
underlying assessment suggests in that
context that the Investments that need
to take place in climate both adaptation
and mitigation needs to rise by three to
six times at least and the way forward
to do that is the intersection of couple
of things one is governments are in fact
Central to give the clear signal that
climate change is imminent and has to
happen and governments can do more with
their public finances that's one element
the equally important element is that
the financial system itself the banks
the central banks The Regulators
themselves have to start recognizing the
urgency and pricing in the risks that
climate action provides and underlying
all of this
Finance needs to flow to places that
need it most as the greatest least
access highest opportunities and that's
in developing countries so we understand
the system that needs to reform needs to
change and it and it's possible to do it
quickly sooner rather than later thank
you
Institute
yeah thank you for that question so this
report is bringing together the state of
the climate science over the last of
what you know now and it's laid out we
tell a little bit about where we are now
talk about where we might go in the
future and then what are the options
available today and so some of the key
messaging out of that report is about
how deep rapid and sustained greenhouse
gas emissions are needed to reach 1.5 as
well as accelerated adaptation to
address the climate change we're already
experiencing and might experience in the
future and the report lays out some
concrete options that are available
today to help address these challenges
thank you very much we will now go for
some of the questions online the
question from Le poix is asking for Dr
Lee first and please do contribute
afterwards how would you describe the
differences between the synthesis report
of this cycle with the previous
synthesis reports our adaptation and
mitigation the most prominent changes
the major difference between the last
one and the current one is the a more
integrated nature integrated approach
for climate science
its impact
impact of climate change and response
measures into this one Standalone
document number two more integrated
analysis about the synergies and
trade-offs between adaptation and
mitigation mostly on the benefits of
integrated approaches for adaptation and
also mitigation and
third it is the probably the most
important aspects we brought in the
human side of the climate change issues
that was a brief mention of the this
Human Side demand side of the climate
issues very briefly in the ar5 synthesis
report but this time
we expanded working groups expanded
greatly the contributions from the
social scientists and working group 3
reports as well as this this synthesis
report very much emphasized the
importance of recognizing the human
dimensions of the climate change issues
and I believe these differences will
probably hopefully to continue
this emphasis on The Human Side as we
will continue to be
attracting much attention not only you
know
the disciple but also for the next cycle
and thereafter so anyone that wishes to
jump in on this matter please
so we'll go first to Aditya then Chris
question I think one thing that's also
different between ar5 and AR6 synthesis
report is the focus on Solutions so we
are being much more Concrete in terms of
what can be actually done and I can talk
a bit more around the adaptation so in
the synthesis report but also in the
underlying reports we actually lay out a
large number of adaptation options and
make the point that adaptation options
would be very context specific something
that can have very high adaptation you
know improve the resilience in one
context can we also maladaptive in
another context so therefore to make
those correct and right decisions the
importance of of consultation the
importance of including the local
Community Voices exactly those who are
being more affected most affected being
a part of that decision making so I
think we lay down the technological
solutions but we say technology alone
will not take us there unless we have
the right Institution policies and this
is where a lot of the climate resilient
development kind of discussions comes in
thank you
foreign thank you for the question I
think this report also makes clear that
action to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions and adapt to the impacts of
climate change is more urgent than
previously assessed in ar5 and that this
decade actions in this decade are
critical for securing a sustainable
future for all
I'd also like to emphasize the report
has a more integrated assessment than we
have had before on the linkages between
adaptation and mitigation actions and
that there are multiple co-benefits both
in ecosystems and for human health by
integrating adaptation and mitigation
for example reducing greenhouse gas
emissions which are often co-emitted
with other near surface air pollutants
can have huge benefits for improving
human health shifts to sustainable
healthy diets can also benefit
biodiversity by opening up land for
ecosystem restoration so the report
points in detail
more than in ar5 to the multiple
co-benefits we can achieve not just for
the climate but also for society and
biodiversity by taking more rapid
climate action
thank you very much next question is for
the secretary Abdullah moxit it's from
Maxime Menge from West France the
question is what could be the main aims
of the next assessment cycle and is the
ipcc reflecting on the shift in panels
written of publication of reports
thank you very much
following the past practice
it's at the end of each cycle we have a
plenary dedicated to listen learn as
well as future of ipcc
now what is expected for next cycle is
to consider
already well selected special report
about climate change and cities and also
a report about
sort living climate forces
and of course during this Greenery for
the future of fpcc we will listen to the
request from for from governance what to
kind of next special ship or support
report will be included
this is about the report but also what
is the focus
for ipcc for next cycle and I as I
highlighted already
the percentage of con of participation
from developing countries will be
improved as well as the percentage of
participation of gender will be also
improved not only this and it was
already something was was a what was
highlighted in this plenary is also the
inclusion of antigenous people
antigenous knowledge as well as
involvement for young scientists
in another world the next cycle will be
more open to any participation this is
our
future our attention and plan for to
improve the next cycle thank you very
much
thank you the next question is from
Mitchell beer the question is how do you
see this report Shifting the focus or
outcome of the global stock take at cop
28.
this report is the resource for the
policy makers in addressing the
challenges and tasks posed for the
global stock take Global tactic is as
you know very well these two address the
way under to understand mutually where
we are where we are and where we want to
be and what is required to achieve that
goal and our report is organized in such
such a way that all the key findings of
underlying working group one Sublime
science working group 2 impacts and
adaptation vulnerability and the three
the response measures are integrated and
summarized into this summer into the
sentence report so we believe that this
report is a standalone report to be a
very effective safe guide for policers
and along with the six reports we
already produced those three Special
Report and working group reports will
provide a variable resource for the
policy makers to address the key tasks
for the global stock take and it more
this contributions will be very much
appreciated
okay the next question and perhaps this
is for maybe for Peter Thorne and Lee Dr
Lee based on based on the current
science this is a question from Barbara
Moran based on the current science when
do you expect the global temperature to
exceed 1.5 degrees Celsius over
pre-industrial levels
okay thank you for the question
um in the synthesis we took the findings
from both work in group one and working
group three and the the finding is that
almost irrespective of our emissions
choices in the near term we will
probably reach one and a half degrees
in the first half of the next decade the
real question is whether I will to
reduce emissions quickly means we reach
one and a half degrees
maybe go a little bit over but then come
back down
or whether we go blasting through one
and a half degrees
go through even two degrees and keep on
going so the future really is in our
hands
we will in all probability reach around
one and a half degrees early next decade
but after that it really is our choices
this is why this the rest of this decade
is key the rest of this decade is
whether we can apply the brakes and stop
the warming at that level
thank you very much the next question is
for Dr Lee from zetland Thomas hebsgard
covering climate science it can often
feel like the same points are being
repeated again and again
that time is running out what do you
think are the most important new
insights from this report and do you
ever feel like you are forced to repeat
the same message over and over again
what we need science is clear on the
issues of climate change what we need
from now is a political will on the
power policy makers also on the part of
constituents that
determined who will be the political
leaders in each this in each domain of
their concern now the second point is we
need a public support to
take the immediate action
so that the climate neutral climate
neutral and
carbon neutral world
be a realistic world we will have and
the last point I want to emphasize is
there must be a personal motivation to
be on that trajectory toward Net Zero
goal so do I believe these three things
are the necessary element for the
science to be transformed into a
political outcome
anyone who wish to add please
Aditi please yep
one of the new messages is this report I
think effectively bursts the myth of
endless adaptation the report clearly
shows that at higher temperature levels
the effectiveness of adaptation will go
down rapidly so unless mitigation also
happens at the pace that's required many
of the adaptation that we are investing
now will not remain as effective as they
are today so I think that's a new and an
important message thank you
thank you very much the next question is
for Gerhard krinner it is sorry it is
from ingeborg who said Ahmed monsen
even if we take action now is it
realistic that global warming will slow
down
thank you
um so the question was even if we take
action now is it realistic that a global
warming will slow down and the answer is
yes if we take action now if we reduce
emissions strongly global warming will
slow down we will see the effects on the
global mean temperature Trends within 20
years it's not an immediate effect to
see but it it will be discernible within
20 years if we take action now so this
is absolutely clear thank you
and let me just add one point that is
linked to that question about 1.5
degrees as Peter Thorne has already said
we now have in 2030 for each individual
year a chance of 40 to 60 percent that
the global mean temperature will exceed
1.5 degrees which does not mean that we
will have reach by that point uh 1.5
degree global warming level in the long
term there's a difference between an
individual year and long-term warning
thank you
okay the next question
um is from Alistair Doyle
um it's for Peter Thorin the question is
this I work for Thompson Reuters
Foundation the report highlights
individual actions like mentions of
cycling walking low carbon diets mental
health
Etc what is driving this change is the
ipcc trying to enlist everyone in action
because governments are failing are
falling short
so this is this synthesis report is is
there's a synthesis of the underlying
findings of the underlying literature
it's uh it's ultimately true that
emissions are the result of our
individual
actions we are the ultimate consumers
that we are the ultimate people driving
or cycling or walking
Etc we need to be enabled by governments
uh production is needed at all levels
from intergovernmental through
governments through communities to
individuals
um we are beyond the point where as the
late great Douglas Adam would say
climate change can be somebody else's
problem if we had had the foresight to
act in 1990 to start to act in a
meaningful way in 1990 we would have a
vast Vista of options available to us to
still avoid one of keep well below two
degrees and strive for one and a half
degrees the reality is we at all levels
governments communities individuals have
made climate change somebody else's
problem we have to stop that we have to
act now it is action across all scales
do not say it is your government's
problem your community's problem it is
your problem as part of that Community
as part of that country to make make the
difference at this point for the
resilient future we need that is
resilient to the climate change we
absolutely have and avoids as much
additional climate change as humanly
possible thank you thank you Peter I
believe Kate would like to contribute
yeah one of the roles of the ipcc report
is to bring science and help inform
decision making at all scales and so in
the synthesis report we assess a number
of different options and what their
their implications would be for
emissions how much they cost what we
know about their effects on biodiversity
or food security or water security and
we do this for a number of actions
across different sectors and systems we
have information about energy options in
the energy systems options in land
options in cities and settlements and
our role is to bring the science
information so that we can help inform
decision making
thank you very much and the next
question is from The Washington Post
from Sarah Kaplan it's for Dr Lee Ken
report authors respond to the
secretary's General call for developed
Nations to reach Net Zero by 2040 a
decade before the rest of the world is
this in keeping with the findings of the
synthesis report and this assessment
cycle and would what would need to
happen to make it a reality
foreign
yes it's consistent because the ipcc's
ipcs is a conclusion on our first
conclusion on the Net Zero by 2050 means
This Global that's that's means global
average therefore some parts of the
countries or regions must have the that
global net zero not Net Zero goal much
earlier than 2050 so is it consistent
his message consistent with the ipcc
synthesis report conclusion which is
also based upon the underlying reports
now what can be done from those regions
who could who could achieve can achieve
the much earlier neutral Newton carbon
neutrality goal well
those countries were able to pursue a
much faster reduction of carbon
emissions they have the technology
finance and I hope political will
therefore they are in much better shape
than other parts of the world to be on
the trajectory towards the carbon
neutrality by 2050.
thank you very much the next question
and I believe it's going to be our last
one because we are close to 3 P.M is
from Seth Bornstein from the Associated
Press it's directed to all panel
scientists but perhaps Aditi may want to
start first for panel scientists the
Secretary General called on developed
Nations to act faster how important is
it that rich Nations act quicker than
poorer and can you talk about how
historical emissions and Equity Factor
are in there in the report if they do
how much of the problem can be fixed by
Rich Nations
let me answer first and then probably uh
invite the others to join that reply the
uh
Rich Nations I believe you mentioned
there has the technology has the finest
and
Dr
the Gupta already mentioned to achieve
that climate goals we need to increase
dramatically almost three to six times
the climate Finance directed to that the
climate stabilization gone the question
is why
why
of sufficient even if sufficient capital
is available why those capital
is not allocated to this urgent serving
the Urgent problems of climate issues
that's the key question one we really
have to think clearly
there are many crises we face every day
and the current Gap existing in gap in
the financial sector implies that the
financial sector must have a different
calculations than the
our scientists think about the necessary
Financial flows to the adaptation and
mitigation now
the countries endowed with a rich
technology and Rich Financial Resources
here has the responsibility as well
recognized by the climate convention and
Paris agreement to help the other
regions
that's lacking those resources so that
all of us can have a better future
maybe invite others to join thank you
Aditi would you like to contribute
or
you
so we are I think on the on the on the
under questions that are on the issues
that we've raised
and that Dr Lee talked about the really
the choices that we are now facing are
more critical and more urgent than ever
before and it's taking place in the
context where there are some progress
It's not that there has been no progress
but the scale of progress that we need
to move towards Dr Lee suggests needs to
really
it's Port feasible and it's possible and
we are more waiting for a combination of
actions bought by governments to make it
feasible and possible and for the
financial system and financial sector
the banks the The Regulators the the
Pension funds the others to start
investing cross-borders and deeply not
just for mitigation but to also the
public finances need to play a critical
role in getting the financing needs for
the enormous adaptation gains and these
are investments that at the end of the
day have huge rates of return socially
and economically the single biggest the
highest return our assessment suggests
May well be providing energy access in
low incomes sub-Saharan Africa it could
be one of the highest return
opportunities that we have right now and
that's not even counting even greater
return opportunities if one were to
address the
in the losses and damages and avoiding
and averting some of these costs from
missing adaptation funding
thank you very much we also have one
question for Chris
this is from the Portuguese paper
publico we have established human
responsibility in climate change and
there are losses and damages already
happening all over the world because of
it now we have to be prepared to pay the
price of these damages and practice
climate Justice oop question mark
so the synthesis report and the
underlying reports it draws on such as
the working group 2 report on climate
impacts adaptation and vulnerability
have stronger evidence than ever before
of loss and damage from climate change
and that negative impacts of climate
change are occurring in all regions
it also shows that low-income groups
have the largest gaps in adapting to
climate change and that climate justice
social justice and other Equitable
approaches can help close these gaps in
adapting to climate change as well as
broaden and widen support across Society
for reducing greenhouse gas emissions
and helping deliver the scaled up and
far-reaching climate action we need in
this decade in order to limit global
warming close to 1.5 and avoid the worst
impacts from climate change lastly the
report has a high confidence that the
greatest gains in well-being especially
in urban areas can come from
prioritizing climate risk reduction for
low-income and marginalized groups
especially people living in informal
settlements
thank you very much we will be now
wrapping up just to check uh Dr Lee if
there are any additional thoughts that
you would like to share with the press
conference before we close
let me just point out one factor the in
this report the walking group worth one
two three reports and census report I
want to highlight this point in ar5
there was an attempt to compare benefits
and costs and the conclusion at that
time was that the ranges of the benefits
of climate action and mostly benefits of
climate action was so large that
meaningful assessment meaningful
conclusion could not be drawn and this
time this artist is involved in this
aspect in the mostly in the working
three three and two uh found that the
global benefit global economic benefit
of pursuing two degree celsius
stabilization outweigh the global cost
of mitigation so that's a significant
message that this report contains which
the ar5 reports did not have
thank you very much
thank you very much and with that we
will close today's press conference I
would like to thank all of the panelists
for being here today and delivering
these important scientific messages to
the global audience
I would also like to thank all of the
journalists who have joined us today
both here in the room and online as I
said we have all together over 800
registered journalists following this
press conference thank you very much
take care and until next time bye bye